Neutron stars are one of the most extreme and violent things in the
universe. Giant atomic nuclei,
only a few kilometers in diameter,
but as massive as stars and they owe their existence to the death
of something majestic
Stars exist because of a fragile balance.
The massive millions of billions of trillions of tons of hot plasma
are being pulled in woods by gravity and squeeze material together with so much
force that nuclei fuse hydrogen fuses into helium.
This releases energy, which pushes against gravity and tries to escape.
As long as this balance exists, stars are pretty stable.
Eventually the hydrogen will be exhausted.
Medium stars like our sun go through a giant phase where they burn helium into
carbon and oxygen before they eventually turn into white dwarfs.
But in stars,
many times the mass of our sun things get interesting when the helium is
exhausted for a moment,
the balance of pressure and radiation tips and gravity wins squeezing the star
tighter than before the core burns,
hotter and faster while the outer layers of the star swell by hundreds of times,
fusing heavier and heavier animates. Carbon burns to neon and centuries,
neon to oxygen in a year,
oxygen to Silicon and months and Silicon to iron in a day.
And then death. Iron is nuclear Ash.
It has no energy to give and cannot be fused.
The fusion suddenly stops and the balance ends without the outward pressure from
fusion. The core is crushed by the enormous weight of the star above it.
What happens now is awesome and scary particles like
electrons and protons really don't want to be near each other.
But the pressure of the collapsing staff is so great that electrons and protons
fuse into neutrons, which then gets squeezed together as tightly,
as in atomic nuclei, an iron ball,
the size of the earth is squeezed into a ball of pure nuclear matter,
the size of a city, but not just the core.
The whole star implodes gravity pulling the outer layers in at
25%, the speed of light.
This implosion bounces off the iron core,
producing a shockwave that explodes outwards and catapults the rest of the star
into space.
This is what we call a supernova explosion and it will out shine entire
Ganek says what remains of the star is now a neutron star.
Its mass is around a million times, the mass of the earth,
but compressed to an object about 25 kilometers wide.
It's so dense.
The massive all living humans would fit into one cubic centimeter of neutron
star matter. That's roughly a billion tons in a space.
The size of a sugar cube put another way.
That's Mount Everest in a cup of coffee from the outside.
A neutron star is unbelievably extreme.
It's gravity is the strongest outside black holes. And if it were any denser,
it will become one light is bent around it.
Meaning you can see the front end parts of the back.
Their surfaces reach a million degrees Celsius compared to a measly 6,000
degrees for our son. Okay. Let's look inside a neutron star.
Although these giant atomic nuclei are stars in many ways.
They're also like planets with solid crusts over a liquid core.
The crust is extremely hard.
The outermost layers are made of iron leftover from the supernova squeeze
together in a crystal lattice with a sea of electrons, flowing through them,
going deeper gravity, squeezes nuclei, closer together.
We find fewer and fewer protons as most merged to neutrons until
we reach the base of the crust here,
nuclei are squeezed together so hard that they start to touch protons and
neutrons rearrange making long cylinders or sheets,
enormous nuclei with millions of protons and neutrons shaped like spaghetti and
the Sanya,
which physicists call nuclear pastor nuclear pastor is so
dense that it may be the strongest material in the universe.
Basically unbreakable lumps of pasta inside a neutron star can
even make mountains at most, a few centimeters high,
but many times as massive as the Himalayas eventually beneath the
pastor, we reached the core.
We're not really sure what the properties of matter are when they're squeezed
this heart protons and neutrons might dissolve into an ocean of quarks.
The so-called Clark gluon plasma.
Some of those quarks might turn into strange quarks,
making a sort of strange matter with properties.
So extreme that we made a whole video about it,
or maybe they just stay protons and neutrons. No one knows for sure.
And that's why we do signs. That's all pretty heavy stuff, literally.
So let's go back out into space. When neutron stars first collapsed,
they began to spin very, very fast, like a battery,
no pulling her arms in neutron stars are celestial batteries spinning
many times per second.
This creates pulses because their magnetic field creates a beam of radio waves,
which passes every time they spend these radio pulsars are the best
known type of neutron star, about $2,000 loan off in the Milky way.
These magnetic fields are the strongest in the universe. A quadrillion times,
stronger than earth after they're born,
they're called magnetism until they come down a little,
but the absolute best kind of neutron stars are friends with other neutron stars
by radiating away energy as gravitational waves ripples in space time,
their orbits can decay and they can crash into and hit each other in a killing
over explosion that spews out a lot of their guards when they do the
conditions become so extreme. That for a moment, heavy nuclei are made. Again,
it's not fusion putting nuclei together this time, but heavy neutron,
rich matter, falling apart and reassembling only very recently,
we've learned that this is probably the origin of most of the heavy elements in
the universe like gold uranium and platinum and dozens more.
So then out two neutron stars collapse and become a black hole dying yet. Again,
not only to stars have to die to create elements.
They have to die twice over millions of years.
These atoms will mix back into the galaxy, but some of them end up in a cloud,
which gravity pulls together to form stars and planets repeating the cycle.
Our solar system is one example and the remains of those neutron stars that came
before us are all around us.
Our entire technological modern world was built out of the elements neutron
stars made in Ian's past sending these atoms on a 13 billion year
journey to come together and make us and our world.
And that's pretty cool
until then we can look at them on paper.
The 12,020 human space era calendar has arrived.
You can order it now until we sell out and then never again,
visit the cloudy cities of Venus Dyson swarm assembly on mercury
and cross the borders of our solar system,
shipping from the U S and from Europe for the first time.
But we deliver to every country all over the world.
You could also get a plushy or hoodie or poster.
We have some sweet deals for you. Get it for Christmas, for your friends,
families, and kids,
or to distract yourself from the fact that there are 100 billion billion
Earth-like planets in the habitable zone of sun-like stars in the observable
universe. And you will never visit any of them.
The last few years we've sold them all. So no rush, but the clock is ticking.
Getting stuff from our shop is one of the best ways to support coats because out
because of you,
we can keep this channel free for everyone and make more beautiful things.
A happy InterStudy year, 12,020.